you know what's crazy I used to work as
a journalist and I went filming in
London several years ago at a school
there was like this big sports day event
happening and some woman got on the mic
and she starts going and it doesn't
matter what gender you are and what
sexuality you are love is love and I was
like it's sports day like why are we why
do you I'm waiting for the egg and Spoon
race right can we just focus on like the
100 meter can we focus on the egg and
Spoon race whatever it is and it doesn't
matter what G like it's so unnecessary
that is not and then you also have to
understand like number one it's just
inappropriate too like how distracting
is all of that from what they actually
need to learn